the World to Sing Sing With Me
[Music]
you may remember this in 1971 this
television commercial for Coca-Cola
revolutionized the ad industry at the
time it was the most expensive
commercial ever produced and that song
became a hit on the Billboard charts in
that very same year another TV spot
debuted that is likely just as memorable
but last week steps were taken to ensure
that will it will never be seen widely
ever again
it was just a minute long but the public
service announcement immediately
captured audiences when it first aired
on Earth Day in 1971 a stereotype of a
Native American character Travels by
canoe through a trash stream landscape
and as the dramatic music swells a bag
of junk thrown from a passing car lands
at his feet while a single tier streams
down his cheek
ad for the non-profit keep America
beautiful was meant to raise awareness
about littering but it also became a
cultural Milestone airing for more than
a decade and parodied in film and
television for Generations Robert
Thompson is a professor of television
and popular culture at Syracuse
University so this commercial uh was
seen by a lot of people and unlike a
television episode which airs once and
then again in a rerun
um this played over and over and over
again growing up in the 1970s if you
were exposed to television at all it
would have been pretty impossible not to
have seen this but last week keep
America beautiful announced it's
donating the rights of the PSA to the
National Congress of American Indians
Jenny Lawson is the CEO of keep America
beautiful this ad doesn't play anymore
on television it hasn't played for quite
some time on TV so what's why is it
important to do it even at this juncture
as I said I think it's important because
the ad still gets a lot of attention we
had regularly received interest in
whether it could be run for
entertainment purposes whether it could
be run for research and education
purposes and so deciding the answers to
that question really needed to move to
the Native American people and we are
pleased that we were able to make that
happen in a statement the ncai says the
ad will only be used for historical
context this advertisement was
inappropriate then and remains
inappropriate today ncai looks forward
to putting this advertisement to bed for
good it reduces us to just one thing
that's what stereotypes do Ashley Minner
Jones is an assistant curator for
history and culture at the Smithsonian
National Museum of the American Indian
it perpetuates The Stereotype that
American Indian people are only of the
past that we only dress one way look one
way all also the man in the commercial
appears to have no agency over his
circumstances that's just not
you know we're human beings we do have
agency ironically at the time that this
commercial was originally released real
Indian activists were occupying Alcatraz
Island in the same body of water where
this man is paddling compounding the
criticism of the ad the fact that the
Native American character was played by
Iron Eyes Cody a well-known actor from
Hollywood westerns was not Native
American he profited off of this false
identity as he he claimed to be Cherokee
now that the ad is out of circulation
Minner Jones is hopeful for more
accurate portrayals of Native Americans
in popular culture when you only see
depictions of native people who are of
the past who look one way who talk one
way
uh it does something to you it almost
causes you to disappear we're an
important moment now where Native people
are beginning to control narratives
about Native people and even produce
mainstream narratives about native
people like reservation dogs Rutherford
Falls and that's just huge for us we
have authentic representation
and this is such an important
conversation to be had at the time when
this was played it was played so many
times that television stations would
have their tapes run out or the tape
would fall apart I remember it so many
times yeah I do remember it you
mentioned reservation dogs there at the
end worth checking out by the way great
show really important too that you may
not be able to redo what you did in the
past what was wrong but important now
when you know that and to be on the
record about it right exactly